[Music]
as we said at the top of the show
president biden spoke for a second time
with russian president vladimir putin
about ransomware attacks
and the president says it makes sense
for the u.s to fight back
if putin doesn't act national security
correspondent jennifer griffin has the
latest tonight from the pentagon
just days after president biden promised
to send a message to vladimir putin the
next time a ransomware or
cyber attack emanated from russian soil
biden placed a phone call to putin i
made it very
clear to him that the united states
expects
when ransomware operation is coming from
his soil even though it's
not not sponsored by the state
expect them to act and give them enough
information to act on who that is
putin has denied any knowledge of these
attacks
you've set up immediate communications
now
on a regular basis to be able to
communicate to one another when each of
us thinks something's happening in
another country that affects
the home country and so it went well i'm
optimistic
the call lasted roughly an hour the
kremlin says the u.s has not presented
any requests
since the biden putin summit in geneva
to stop criminal cyber attacks
quote over the past month no requests
have been received from the competent
u.s departments on these issues not true
according to a senior administration
official who says the u.s has made
several
specific requests to russian authorities
for action on cyber crime
you said three weeks ago there would be
consequences will there be sir
yes biden said as much last month after
meeting with putin
he knows i will take action he knows
their consequences
it's not clear putin got the message the
russian cyber gang
r evil claimed responsibility for the
latest ransomware attack which hit more
than fifteen hundred businesses
across 17 countries over the july 4
weekend
we don't have additional or new
information suggesting the russian
government directed
these attacks a senior administration
official told reporters the u.s response
will take place in the days and weeks
ahead
but refuse to telegraph what those
actions would be
adding some might be invisible some
might not
shannon all right jennifer griffin
at the pentagon thank you very much
we'll have more with this with the panel